[Music]
my dear cousin that odd Nations
cherished each other as we would to King
James 2:19 Margo is Elizabeth the first
Queen of England
Saoirse Ronan is Mary Queen of Scotland
the truer relatives and bitter rivals
Queen Elizabeth your cousin Mary has
returned to take up her throne in
Scotland Margot underwent quite the
transformation to play the daughter of
Henry the eighth and almost didn't
recognize herself when pictures from the
set were published
I am the day it was like Baltimore I've
got like the noise and like the oldest
or aesthetics how long is that in here
make up by three and a half hours my
dear cousin Elizabeth I hope we might
meet in person as I might embrace you
these two women waged a bloodthirsty
battle for the crown I know your heart
has more within it than the men who
counseled you you would do well to watch
your birth I will not be scolded by my
inferior she's an amazing person and one
of those people that like keeps keep
serve people close and and she's got our
priorities in order
so yes so it's great that we're getting
to do all this together you know they're
bitter few becomes even more intense
when Mary gives birth to a boy an heir
to the throne of England while Elizabeth
remained childless what makes the story
more fascinating it's all true now I see
there's no close ending
your gifts will be your downfall should
you murder me remember you murder your
sister and you murder your queen
[Music]